[Musique]
nous sommes le 19 janvier 2017 bonsoir
et bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8
les invités émission dédiée à celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département voici les titres
nathan 9 ans est atteint d'une maladie
neurologique orpheline pour l'aider à
aller mieux ses parents lui font suivre
notamment des traitements à l'étranger
des déplacements des voyages qui coûte
cher une soirée est organisée ce samedi
au cabaret du bout des prêts de cerner
la ville pour récolter des fonds
le parrain de l'association journaliste
franck et d'art nous en dira plus dans
quelques instants et puis l'école 3 i/s
à elancourt organise des journées portes
ouvertes ce week end
nous allons donc parler de ces métiers
de l'audiovisuel pardon avec emmanuel
carré directeur de la pédagogie
bonsoir emmanuel carré et bienvenue dans
quelques instants on va parler de
l'actualité de votre établissement et
mais tout d'abord il est question elle
d'un combat un combat mené par un jeune
garçon de 9 ans bonsoir franck et d'art
bonsoir août vous êtes journaliste
notamment chez nos confrères de m6 vous
mettez votre notoriété à profit pour
aider les parents de cet enfant ce jeune
garçon a à récolter des fonds alors déjà
expliqué nous un peu qu'on comprenne sa
maladie la maladie dont souffre nathan
parle d'une maladie rare alors c'est une
maladie neurologique orpheline
nathan a aujourd'hui innovants il est
non et donc en 2007 et ses dix mois
après sa naissance que ses parents se
sont aperçus qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui clochait
ça a commencé par départ des
vomissements des crises d'épilepsie
et puis il est tombé dans un semi coma
tous à l'âge de 10 mois
il réagissait plus troubles de la
concentration etc
et là ils se sont aperçus qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui clochait sont suivis
des mois d'hospitalisation des examens
médicaux pour déterminer que finalement
il était atteint d'une maladie
neurologique orpheline qui qui a les
handicapés sont son développement donc
ça provoque des troubles
des troubles psychiques ça provoque de
l'autisme et des troubles moteurs et les
médicaments sont inefficaces et les
médicaments sont inefficaces
il ya eu un traitement pour traiter son
épilepsie qui qui a commencé à être
efficaces mais en fait ce qui a vraiment
marché
c'est que les parents se sont tournés
vers d'autres parents dont les enfants
souffraient de troubles
un peu un peu similaire et du coup ses
parents leur ont conseillé de tenter
d'autres d'autres méthodes n'est pas des
médecines parallèles mais on y est
presque puisque c'est à base de
kinésithérapie de massage de choses qui
ne se font pas forcément en france ce
qui les amène à aller en espagne puisque
l'espagne est l'un des trois pays aka
pologne les états unis qui propose des
méthodes un peu novatrice pour traiter
ce genre de pathologie
donc ça permet de stimuler ses muscles
ça le permet à lui permet aussi
d'apprendre à se tenir debout alors on
stimule à la fois ses muscles et aussi
on stimule son cerveau du coup bas en
quelques en quelques séances et il a
fait huit stages en nous ces dernières
années m des résultats conclut des
résultats concrets des progrès puisque
il a commencé à pouvoir s'asseoir il a
commencé à pouvoir se déplacer sur ses
fesses il a commencé aussi dernièrement
là depuis l'année dernière et bien à
pouvoir tenir debout avec de l'aide avec
de l'appareillage comme on peut le voir
sur ces images mais il commence à les
progrès sont les progrès sont notables
ça veut dire qu'en france il ya un
certain retard sur sur ces médecines en
tout cas sur cette approche là des
thérapies contre pas forcément un retard
mais en tout cas les la médecine
traditionnelle en france ne va pas
prendre en compte ce qui existe ailleurs
ce qui peut se faire ailleurs
et tout ça coûte cher ils tous à se
rendre à l'étranger rien que le
déplacement déjà coûte cher et en plus
faire appel à ces thérapeutes d'un autre
style d'un autre type ça coûte plus cher
c'est ça on un stage va coûter à peu
près 5000 euros pour trois semaines
le stage commence à se décompose ces
quatre heures 4 heures sur une
demi-journée donc quatre heures le matin
du lundi au vendredi et c'est assez
intensif faut imaginer un petit garçon
qui a aujourd'hui neuf ans nathan faut
le stimuler on stimule ses muscles on
stimule son cerveau donc c'est quelque
chose qui est très épuisant pour lui et
pendant ces quatre heures ça va être
voilà ça va être ça va être intensifiée
va être avec un kiné il va être avec
quelqu'un qui va lui faire des massages
qui va lui faire avec des petites
électrodes des petits capteurs qui sont
placés sur sur son cv au cerveau qui
vont enregistrer ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe dans sa tête puisque l'usiné
s'exprime quand ça n'est pas douloureux
pour autant non c'est pas d'où l'on n'a
pas précisé non non c'est quand même
important de le dire
faut récolter des fonds forcément ça
coûte cher on va on va y venir à cette
soirée qui est organisée samedi au
cabaret du bout des prêts à cerner la
ville juste avant d'en parler expliqué
nous un peu votre démarche pourquoi
avoir choisi d'être parrain de cette
association est ce petit garçon alors
comment ça s'est passé on a quelqu'un
sur sur notre plateau à m6 qui s'appelle
christian christian c'est notre chef
plateau c'est notre ange gardien cirque
c'est lui qui va nous régler la clim qui
soit parfait de température c'est lui
qui va nous apporter les verres d'eau
c'est lui qui va intervenir dès qu'il ya
un problème sur le sur le plateau pour
nous mettre en confiance va nous
indiquer les caméras qu'il faut regarder
christian nous donnerait son numéro
s'était passé avec plaisir c'est
christian qui m'a fait rencontrer
stéphanie et gaëtan et puis le petit le
petit nathan il avait besoin de
quelqu'un pour animer la soirée
inattendue puisque là ça va être la
quatrième la quatrième édition avait
besoin de quelqu'un pour animer cette
soirée
il ya quelques quelques années et puis
on s'est bien entendu il y avait une
marraine
emilie de la place miss picardie 2015 et
il cherchait un par un et ils m'ont
demandé si gentiment je pouvais mettre à
profit ma petite notoriété pour les pour
les aider pour les accompagner et
régulièrement il ya des collectes qui
sont organisées il ya plusieurs
événements tout au long de l'année pour
récolter des fonds et il ya donc cette
soirée inattendue
comment va se passer cette soirée
inattendue alors ça va être une attendu
je peux rien je suis venu avec mes
filles parce qu'il ya des choses très
intéressantes qui sont attendus à dire
les choses qui sont attendus y aura des
magiciens qui vont venir il va y avoir
un speed painting
c'est pas du tout ce à quoi vous pensez
wilfred le fonctionnement de narnia
hinting c'est
c'est un peintre avec des paillettes qui
va jeter les paillettes qui va faire le
portrait d'une personnalité
il ya aussi des humoristes qui vont
venir des acrobates des chanteurs des
danseuses avec des plumes beaucoup de
plumes beaucoup de paillettes plus
quelques personnalités qui vont se
joindre se joindre à nous pendant la
soirée et il ya jean philippe doux que
l'on a pu voir notamment sur m6 c'est
aussi chez ils en pensent quoi camille
sur sur s'éviter isabelle morini bosc
journaliste d'rtl et puis que l'on peut
voir aussi dans touche pas à mon poste
et puis je crois qu'il ya philippe
candeloro qui va venir faire un petit et
pour récolter des fonds c'est à dire
qu'il faut payer le billet d'entrée
alors c'est un dîner spectacle à dîner
spectacle 45 euros qui vous profitez de
la soirée vous profitez du spectacle
vous profiter du repas et vous passez un
agréable moment et vous faites un acte
généreux un de solidarité pour aider
nathan nathan le combat d'un ange il ya
un site internet l'adresse est affiché
et puis bien évidemment vous l'avez vu à
la fiche pour cette soirée
quand vous restez en plateau avec nous
avec plus souvent parler le média encore
c'est un milieu que vous connaissez bien
un trio avec l'école troisième qui est à
saint quentin en yvelines sur les
communes des long courriers et de
trappes qui forme aux métiers de
l'audiovisuel rebond soirée mènent carré
vous êtes le directeur de la pédagogie
du développement journée portes ouvertes
ce 21 janvier ce sera juste avant le la
soirée inattendue qui se déroule ensuite
du côté de cerner on va faire un point
global déjà sur cette école troisième
l'école se porte bien aujourd'hui vous
dépasser le millier d'étudiants à peu
près oui on a atteint un millier
d'étudiants à l'école l'école existe
depuis 1988
le bâtiment historique et situé du côté
de la commune de trappes et celui qui
est en exploitation pour l'essentiel de
nos activités où il ya beaucoup
d'équipements et du côté de l'encours
encore comment vous faites la différence
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'écoles qui forme aux métiers de
l'audiovisuel comme en troisième on va y
revenir mais l'école existe depuis la
fin des années 80 si je me trompe pas
c'est ça comment vous faites la
différence
et bien justement c'est par des
opérations comme les journées portes
ouvertes comme montre
notre savoir faire nos équipements qui
font vraiment la différence dans ces
métiers
puisque il faut former les jeunes à des
technologies qui sont contemporaines qui
sont celles qui vont utiliser dans leur
vie professionnelle
ensuite et on a un certain nombre de
plateaux alors un plateau qui équipe est
un peu comme celui dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui pour entraîner les
étudiants qui font la prise de vue la
prise de sauts des apprentis
journalistes qui font également partie
de nos spécialisation on a un studio de
motion capture qui est plus original et
qui et je dirai unique en france dans
dans les écoles puisque là on a 32
caméras qui reproduisent les mouvements
d'un comédien sur le plateau on a un
plateau spectacle vivant on a évidemment
toutes les technologies utiles
aujourd'hui comme la prise de vue
aérienne par drones les casques htc vous
savez qui permet de rentrer dans des
dents des jeux vidéo dans des logiques
de dieu du réalisme et virtuels virtual
voilà donc là on est complètement
dépaysé aucune évolution significative
tout de même entre 1988 la date de
création est aujourd'hui des formations
forme même aux métiers du jeu vidéo
cette année absolument parce que ce qui
s'est passé dans ces trente dernières
années c'est que bert 1988 le
spécialiste de l'image il partait avec
sa caméra à pellicule argentique celui
qui prenait le son avait sa bande son
est aujourd'hui tout ça converge avec le
numérique et a fortiori avec le web il
ya un chiffre consiste à ces souvent
c'est que l'ensemble des images du son
produit pendant toute l'année 1995
oui c'est pas très vieux pendant toute
une année aujourd'hui c'est le même
volume de données et diffuser simplement
en deux minutes sur internet
donc effectivement c'est l'accélération
de technologie fait qu'on doit former
aujourd'hui les jeunes pour manipuler au
plan technique et artistique toutes les
données qui vont faire ensuite de
l'image et du son et donc des industries
créatives ce soit le cinéma le jeu les
films d'animation me tienne
audiovisuelle au sens large c'est
beaucoup de formations qui y sont
qui sont proposés globalement quels sont
les débouchés est ce qu'il ya des
débouchés parce que vous d'expliquer les
technologies évoluent et qui dit
révolution des technologies dit
quelquefois aussi réduction du personnel
puisque avec une seule personne on peut
faire beaucoup de choses
oui il ya des débouchés aujourd'hui et
oui parce qu'on a besoin de spécialistes
des gens qui savent aujourd'hui faire de
la prise de vue aérienne avec un drone
ou qui savent utiliser un atelier de
motion capture et ben forcément c'est
des gens qu'il faut former ces
technologies qui évoluent très vite
donc nous on a la chance d'avoir dette
dans des secteurs très porteurs et on
suit les diplômés ans et ce qu'ils
deviennent
je sais qu'il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont souvent dans votre régie à côté et
on sait qu'on a entre 80 90 % des
diplômés qui ose qui sont en poste dès
l'année de la sortie de l'école parce
que précisément on sait qu'ils sont
formés aux dernières techniques et
qu'ils ont toutes les bases culturelles
et général pour évoluer dans ces métiers
j'aime tournés vers franck et d'art
parce qu'à des élèves de 3e vous en avez
rencontré quelques-uns j'en ai rencontré
quelques-uns dans une autre nuit lorsque
j'étais directeur d'une télévision
locale des yvelines une autre ferme et
une première manche gagnée par être
parée de stagiaires et qui aujourd'hui
il y en a 2 charles ménard et clément
douillet que je salue qui sont dans une
société de production à montréal qui
s'appelle pimiento et on a un autre qui
est très bon aussi qui eux bossent
notamment pour doter et canal+ et
pierre-alexandre toussaint
donc c'est désagréable rencontres
humaines et professionnelles et c'est
vrai que votre école forme des
professionnels de caractère est très bon
mais qui travaillent effectivement de
temps en temps pour ça il ya
l'international parce que feu peut-être
expliquer le sigle 3 i/s c'est
l'institut international de l'image et
du son et vous avez noué on sait qu'on
va être pris par le temps mais je
voudrais qu'on vienne sur deux
événements vous avez noué des
partenariats avec les professionnels
aussi il ya deux événements qui vont se
dérouler prochainement il ya la
cérémonie des lumières tout d'abord ce
sera le 30 janvier
oui alors la cérémonie des lumières
c'est les prix qui sont décernés par l'
agence internationale de presse donc
c'est une grande manifestation ou qui
est un petit peu l'antichambre des
césars et ce sont nos étudiants qui sont
aux commandes de l'organisation de cette
soirée qui font tout puisqu'ils savent
qu'ils vont être dehors la profession
avec aussi bien les artistes les
comédiens les techniciens et on organise
l'ensemble de la
captation de cet événement et de sa
retransmission j'espère aussi sur tv fil
78 puisqu'on est en pourparlers pour le
faire avec l'idée qu'effectivement ils
ont un exercice grandeur nature ça se
passe au théâtre de la madeleine
tout comme les remises de prix les
cérémonies qui ont lieu la deuxième
c'est les lauriers ce sera le 13 février
ça sera du châtelet théâtre du châtelet
avant sa fermeture puisque il va être
ensuite en travaux ce qui fait que les
césar pour lesquelles nous sommes
également partenaires seront cette année
organisée salle pleyel et ce sont aussi
nos étudiants qui font la captation des
événements pour l'académie des césar les
bandes-annonces l'organisation des
soirées ca révélation césars techniques
césar des producteurs donc on essaie
autant que possible de mettre nos jeunes
en situation vraiment de rencontrer les
acteurs de nos professions et de faire
des exercices très concret puisque le
jour où on leur dit cette émission va
être diffusée sur votre chaîne ou sur
tv5 monde
évidemment tout le monde est à son poste
un peu fébrile en disant c'est
aujourd'hui que je fais un vrai exercice
comme dans ma future vie professionnelle
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau est
fermé ce 7,8 les invités pour ce soir je
vais rappeler vos deux actualités tout
d'abord la soirée inattendue le samedi
21 janvier 19h30 afin de récolter des
fonds pour un à temps et puis ces
journées portes ouvertes pour l'école 3
i/s samedi 21 aussi ce sera toute la
journée les différents sites internet se
sont affichées les programmes se
poursuivre sur notre antenne
les replays sur notre site internet et
sur notre application mobile merci à
vous
[Musique]